[Musique]
passe ton bac d'abord et bien ça c'est
fait nos jeunes diplômés se sont
retrouvés à la Bibliothèque
départementale pour fêter comme il se
doit leur passeport pour les études
supérieur la bibliothèque qui les
accueilli pour des révisions faites
aujourd'hui le bac avec eux à l'image
d'Ilana et de Marie qui ont choisi le
calme et la plinitude des lieux pour se
plonger dans les anals de
préparation venez bah disons tous les
jours et et puis bah on faisait une
matière par jour on on s'entraîit en
fait on se faisait réviser l'une et
l'autre les définition c'est et ce qu'on
comprenait pas aussi on s'édait aussi
l'une et l'autre en fait la
tranquillité et le fait que c'est très
studieux les gens autour de moi
travaillaient beaucoup et ça donna une
motivation en plus pour continuer et et
avec l'aide des autres aussi qui étaent
là aussi même si on se connaissait pas
il se disait et voilà ben on l'aura
notre bac et ça motive franchement un
lieu propice aux études c'est sans doute
pour cela que de nombreux étudiants sont
venus peaufiner les différentes matières
qui composent leur série de terminal
l'objectif étant de décrocher le sésame
coûte que coûte très important parce que
ça représente la fierté de la famille ça
représente beaucoup d'années de travail
de patience et pour au final finir par
la plus grosse épreuve et la réussir
quoi Nassima Lindar présidente du
conseil départemental a félicité tous
les bacheliers mais également tous ceux
qui continuent leurs études supérieures
et qui ont obtenu leur licence ou encore
leur entrée dans des grandes écoles et
ce soir nous avons la réunion de
l'excellence il y a ceux qui ont réussi
leur baccalauréat aux parents qui ont
accompagné leurs enfants bravo il y a
ceux qui ont réussi des BTS à vous aussi
et aux parents bravo il y en a qui ont
préparé également une licence et l'ont
obtenu euh une jeune qui aidé de ses
parents boosté par par ses parents
prépare des études de sciences politique
bravo un autre encore qui vient
d'obtenir son capess de mathématique
réviser la Bibliothèque départementale
porte décidément chance à nos lycéens
puisque comme l'année dernière ces
derniers ont réussi leurs examens pour
Laurence massé la bibliothèque permet de
se concentrer forcément de mieux
apprendre ce qui montre bien que
travailler dans une bibliothèque ça
beaucoup d'avantages et en tout cas ça
met les lycéens et les jeunes dans une
dynamique de travail et c'est autant de
gagner pour l'avenir pour leurs études
futures des bacheliers heureux mais
également des parents fiers qui pour
certains ne faitent pas seulement une
réussite mais plusieurs très très fier
il se trouve qu'on a une licance de
cette année donc pour ma grande fille un
bac pour la seconde et un premier prix
de collège pour la 3è et ce n'est pas
notre humoriste préféré Marie alinaman
qui va dire le contraire son fils a
décroché le bac ce qui lui rappelle
quelques
[Applaudissements]
souvenirs
avec sans mention avec le rattrapage
rattrap une pe mention le cru 2015 a
donc été excellent rendez-vous est pris
pour l'année prochaine pour de nouvelles
révisions et surtout de nouveaux
[Musique]
bachelis